it's a Wednesday night and I'm just
hoping the mummer
will be glad to have me back where else
would I be
I'm having a kitchen and so in the bowl
still go going up I mean I wish you
could have been here last night we were
absolutely full what juicer wanna to see
those and downstairs yeah stop boys
having em with some peas not better he
Lauren's actually in a uniform today
it's great to hear that Brian sorted out
his babysitting problems sherita's been
able to take him on full-time as mama
Cherry's head chef and he's a changed
man on weekdays he's running the kitchen
single-handed and he seems to be
thriving on the responsibility that
looks fantastic you're not throwing
things in there anymore now you place
them they're nice they actually look at
you smile what's happened to you over
the last two months
Lords come down and touch to all credit
to Brian he's taking sole in a bowl and
run with it it's looking really fresh
nacho nacho how does it taking now for
food to come out on the tray on the
train taking a bodiless that's about six
seven minutes it's your five minutes so
quick quick as possible as I can be yeah
so you having lost you touch them it's
coming back slowly you know when you
kind of difficult to find yourself back
again you know but at the moment I'm so
into it and I'm gonna get it done
whatever happy the team has been
stripped down and the customer seemed to
love that new improved food it's all
good for business chicken gyro meat
jambalaya hot wings
January's takings are up a staggering
60% on last year despite now being
closed on a Monday and last Saturday
Charita filled the restaurant three
times over with Brian and AD cooking for
a massive 105 customers I'd love to see
you spinning around doing 105 covers you
know that yeah soul in the bowl is
exactly what I wanted him to get some
confidence and I've also created my own
soul and explain in it our seasoning but
note imitation yeah and you know what I
think back that folder what's happening
now is I've got people come in on the
weekdays or during the song the bowl and
then they say to me can't wait to book a
weekend because I know now I'm having
those ribs they weren't enough that
stress has gone that the stress is gone
because now I feel that there is a
future you know anything there was a
future yeah I've got that fire back
inside
yeah and you know where this is going
yeah and I know where it's going and
we're in Kenya
so yeah all you make in the perfect I
will never forget that one if you put it
together now why would it come out your
cake market will come out married in
your cake that means you're cooking the
books
long live mama Terry and her finger
licking food I'll definitely be back for
more